welcome again
and hello everyone my name is kevin
welcome to pi data global 2021 i am your
host i am very happy to be here
for moderate this session now i would
like to welcome omri fema
who is a data hacker maker
and
avi fan of lego really interesting
he is a chief architect at diagnostic
robotics building ai and predictive
analytics
models to make healthcare better cheaper
and more widely available so
uh omar is going to present us
components workflow and code books
building medical grade ai pipelines we
are go workflows so i'm gonna pass it to
you
uh ombre thank you very much
thanks kevin
um so today i want to talk about
building medical grade machine learning
pipelines but actually what i really
want to talk about
is about two things i want to talk about
machine learning pipelines and heart
attacks now why am i an expert about
these two peculiar subjects so first i'm
an architect at diagnostic robotics
i'm an engineer by profession i'm not a
data scientist but
um after enough time working with data
scientists i probably can understand
every second word that you say
um
and what we do at diagnostic robotics is
we build something called ai driven
precision population health which
basically means that
we can take patient data and medical and
clinical data in order to create much
more effective much more efficient and
much more
accurate and personalized treatment
to people and i will show you how it
works
um in just a moment so
the way we do that and actually the way
our machine learning story started like
it's just probably like any other ai
story with a notebook
and we had an experiment and we were
asked to do something which
goes sort of
in the way of okay find me something i
can do now to prevent us
hospitalizations from heart failures in
six months from now
so we did our research and we took the
data and we built a model and everything
works and congratulations there is even
a client who wants to use this uh
modern production a and there is even a
paper so we can now get into production
right
well
almost not so quickly because
it all worked
great when we were talking about 300
that set of 300 000 patients but when we
were talking about a million or 20
million patients
working on notebooks is just not enough
and here comes
mlops
and envelops might mean a lot of things
it may mean governance of data and
managing your model artifacts and
managing the lineage of data but today i
want to focus
on one specific things i want to focus
about pipelines how to create your
entire machining process a lot more
efficient a lot more predictable
and
when you're freaking thinking about it
pipelining orchestration is pretty much
a solve problem right you just need to
choose the tool that
makes my most sense to you
start work with it
most of them has great documentation
great examples out there and start
implementing your code as a pipeline and
start running
and
we specifically chose argo we love argo
one of the reasons that we chose it is
because kubernetes native it's api and
cli firsts which is amazing for us as
engineers it has a really nice ui and
since it's kubernetes first
it allows us to create robust
deployments with helm in argo cd which
we are already familiar with
and that allows us to really create ai
at scale and that's a really small
screenshot of our pipeline looks like
it's much more complex than that
um so great excellent job we now have a
modern production that can work on
with the accuracy and robustness
and the scale that we require um
and now
our product managers or business people
say us okay that's great job now do the
same
for long covey
and i'm looking at my data scientists
and data scientists looking at me
and they're saying oh dear
because
while we were moving from
experimentation to production we've lost
something in the journey
because you know yeah
pipeline orchestration should have
solved the issue of
creating robust machine learning
pipelines but they have introduced a lot
of new complexities
and new troubles
um so
yeah data pipelines look really really
simple in the in the demo
but when you're actually trying to
implement them on something
on a real world problem on something a
little bit more complex than
this simple um pipeline
it becomes a lot more complicated and
suddenly
the file and suddenly you're finding
yourself managing a 3000 line
yaml files that nobody can navigate in
or and everybody are afraid to edit and
modify and modify which is not a great
fun
deployments becomes a lot more
complicated because eventually
what happened is that we don't we don't
have one version
of our pipeline um yeah we have one
version that we consider as our
production
or maybe we have two or three version
one for the old production one is a
candidate for production but we need to
support a lot of other versions of the
pipelines to support our research
approaches and we need to make sure that
um our experimental pipelines do not
override or do not damage our production
grade pipelines
and that
different pipelines from different users
don't override one each other
and that becomes a little bit more
complex
another thing that we found
is troublesome is that iterative
experimentation became
slow so now when i want to work with
pipelines every time i want to
change
something
and give it a try
i need to change push a branch wait for
the docker image to
to be built
push it into our kubernetes cluster and
then go to the argo ui and run
and run my
pipeline
which is
nice but a lot slower than
running your just
clicking something writing a line of
code and just clicking
shift enter and seeing it work in real
time
and that
brought us to some understanding
regarding the duality of research cycles
when we are talking about machine
learning processes
we're actually talking about two
different modes that we're working in
one is the research mode when we need to
be fast experimental we need to be
adjustable and iterative and where the
data scientist is the king
and there is the development mode when
we require scalability we need we
require reliability governance and
robustness when we want our pipelines to
be
to run
reliably in a fire and forget mode this
is where engineering is keen
and the issue is that
the set
they're not the same tools are used to
work on research mode and development
mode
but the issue with medical pipelines is
that we don't only have these two modes
distinct modes
when we're talking about the exploration
and development
it's actually a spectrum so on one hand
we have the production uh
great product which actually influences
people life so
we better not screw that up and there is
the exploration on one other hand which
there aren't too many rules or
regulations but as we go more and more
into uh production there are a few steps
that are still experimental
for example clinical validation or
prospective research where we actually
influence people's lives we need to be
able to react on the other end but we
still need some type of governance we
need to make sure that our processes are
reliable
and um can run in a production grade
once we decide to promote them
so envelopes add complexity and it can
hinder our ability to do experimentation
so what i want to talk with you today is
how to solve that and the solution is
surprisingly nothing more to changing
your tools this solution is
or a lot of it is an architecture
so this talk today is going to be about
our journey from research to production
and back up again to research
so there are four steps that we found
out to be very effective in order to
make our
or to
fix this gap between production and
research so the first step is to
pythonize our pipelines
basically we took this yamu and we've
created um
a very steamed wrapper
built on python and with this
wrapper we'll build in our
pipelines in python and then compile it
back to yaml there are actually several
ways to do that and the neat part here
is that yeah
this code is relatively familiar we
understand how to work with it so this
is an example of a very simple pipeline
where we say okay we want to run a low
from
from a very basic container so we just
put our input params and we can just set
it up in one what we need to run
um and then we can just compile it or
send it directly
into our go compile it and then send it
into our
deployment pipeline
we even have
utilities to run it out of a command
line which is really nice
um so what are the benefits of
pythonizing the dark so
one aspect one aspect it's very
developer friendly and very data
scientist friendly
it's great a single source of truth of
what a pipeline should look like
it has all the great things that we have
encoded so for example autocomplete
schema validation tests linkedin
opinionated apis and scaffolds we can
build upon it and that's probably the
most important aspect of it
the ability to create obstructions over
um the basic language of
of our pipelines something that is very
hard to do once we're talking in yamos
and very easy to do it's basically what
we do every day once we start to talk in
code
um there are several ways to do that um
there's the kubeflow pipeline compiler
there's cooler and there's pi argo dsl
it allows you to do that we chose just
to um
to just build um
[Music]
python files or pipeline python schemas
out of the
original argo dsl schemas and i'll show
you how you can do that
later
and the really neat part is that once
you treat pipelines as compilable code
it's easy to bring engineering practices
and patterns for example
let's see let's have a look on this
basic pipeline and how we've changed it
in order to bring obstruction into the
game
so a lot of time our engineers or data
scientists don't really care about the
image and resources and a lot of aspects
which are let's call it technical
aspects and not part of their daily
business to
daily business life
so what was trying to do like you're
seeing in line one
um
we took all this and i obstructed it out
and into a very nice name and we just
import it and use it
and what we get uh for free is that we
get a very opinionated api that explains
how to use it which makes us life a lot
easier
and allows us to define things for
example as resources which are basically
the kubernetes resources that we might
need and when you ask um that a data
scientist what kubernetes resources you
might need they might look at you a
little bit strange
and you we've just gave them some sort
of a business um
a business or domain
name which makes things a lot more
easier instead of yeah give me a 5 cp a
4 cpu 64 gigabyte machine no there is an
app machine that works for very small
things that's what you need
the second aspect
once you've titanized your code piped in
as your pipeline we can now talk about
pipeline architectures and to talk about
pipeline architecture i want to talk a
little bit about something else
about hamburgers
specifically in and out burgers if
you're not if you're not aware of in and
out in and out is um
a chain of uh
fast is a fast food chain
from the west coast
and what they became famous of
is their secret menu
basically you can order a list of very
crazy dishes um from the
protein style which replaces
the buns in lettuce or the foreign for
animal style with somewhere with
heights somewhere over here
um and the neat part when you look about
how um
in and out burger
secret many works is that they give you
a lot of possibilities to customize
but they are doing it with the same
seven or eight ingredients that they can
source in a very efficient very
consistent and very high quality way
so
when they're talking about ingredients
there's a very there's a very limited
set of ingredients that they are
making sure that they do right
but when
there is the choice of combining these
ingredients together they they're giving
it a choice uh to combine it as you wish
and if we're talking about heart attacks
and i've promised you machine learning
pipelines enough of the text so yeah
sometimes these combinations make sense
and in this case probably they don't
make sense but it's your work as a
customer to decide it's your job to
decide if it makes sense or not to a
particular case probably
um
so we took the um in and out secret menu
um concept into the way we build or
manage our pipeline assets
and we are splitting our pipelines into
three different types of components
one is a component the component is a
reusable piece of code and pattern that
we can use to abstract out things that
our data scientists and data engineers
are not really interested in and i'll
show you an example in a moment
another element is workflows workflows
are reusable atomic pieces of work
they can be consumed independently or as
part of a larger cookbook
and the idea behind that is that
workflows are closely managed or closely
curated and basically we make sure that
our workflows always work in our at the
highest level
and highest quality possible and now we
have cube books cookbooks are basically
menus it's a combination of one or more
workflows or even other cookbooks
download for a very specific task so
um their lifetime might be limited so we
might use them for an experiment and
feel free to just
um delete them after they live their
usefulness
um so let's talk about components see a
little bit how they work so
components in our basic um
might be things that you might want to
abstract from users for example
kubernetes resource management
configuration injection how you handle
secrets how you handle common
environment settings and things like
that there might be common templates
that will help you create a more
opinionated pipelines and make your
developer life a lot easier and there
might be scaffolds that will help you to
develop things a lot quicker so here's a
quick example of how such um
component look like so that's a company
that defines
um our an etl machine which
which with memory has and one it thinks
that um
that we've added that in debug mode we
can actually reduce
the amount of memories so we can
actually run it on a smaller machine
when we're trying to compile
the same pipeline once for debug
environment and once for the production
environment
another element is
configuring secrets which again
that's a lot of code most of the data
engineers and data scientists are not
interested in that we cannot start it
out and just reference it um
in our pipelines very easily
so this
can be managed by our devops team
instead of wasting time of everyone
workflows are basically
um the workflows the basic python
workflows that we've seen before what
make war for workflow is it has two
things it has the entry point that
defines all the steps or basically the
dac that is required from
the workflow
and the arguments that are needed in
order to run it independently now in
this steps one of the nice things
when you're designing workflows like
that is that in a very quick glance you
can understand the dependencies of a
workflow you can understand the compute
features target template is dependent on
all of these targets
which make things a lot easier
and of course it makes a lot easier
things are very much easier than when
you're trying to
have a look
on a much more complex workflow
so cookbooks basically are a collection
of these
highly curated uh
workflows that we've built before and
maybe we might had um some ad doc
workflows that we're just building for
some experiments and connecting them all
together into some sort of a business
flow that makes sense
um so we can take all these
cookbooks and create let's say a full
proof process that
trains and serves
a new model or
we can modify it into a process that
trains and serves multiple models into
one hybrid model
um or even if we want to work on an
experimentation mode yeah we can just
push inside
um an ad doc
workflow for sampling data
and then we can create something that
allows us to work
with that
or if we want wish to um
to run our pipelines in a testing
environment or an end-to-end test
we can wrap this workflow in another
end-to-end workflow that is responsible
just to create a test context
run the um previous cookbook in the
previous cookbook and then do some
validation and test cleanup to make sure
that
eventually
this entire
book works properly
um the way we organize it in our code
base is we're actually splitting our
code into these areas of components
which are the curated collection of our
shareable ingredients our workflows
which are shareable reliable and
consistent
building blocks and cookbooks which
again are mixing match of curated
pipelines that can be different from the
environmental environment and developer
and developer
so once you've talked about how we we're
building our pipelines let's talk about
how we're deploying them
um so we have a quickbook menu that we
can just access from our ui and again
one of the issues that we're having
that we're having is okay so i want to
make a small modification in our
cookbook
how do i deploy it
yeah the probably the most trivial way
to do that is just add a prefix and then
you end up with a lot of junk cookbooks
that you need to
somehow find if they if they're
overreading something or destroyed
something else or need to be deleted
or maintained
and we don't want to do that so one
thing we did is to leverage the ability
of argo to do namespace isolation for
pipelines
basically we connect our cookbooks and
our branches into different name spaces
so once we do git push um
to our git with new pipelines these
pythons are getting built and deployed
automatically to a dedicated namespace
and then if i'm working on expert on an
experimental branch i can make sure that
all of the pipelines that i need to work
with are already there waiting for me
and are deployed automatically if i'm
working on a production branch i know
that our my pipelines are isolated from
any other experimental branches
that might be there
our pipeline is working on
argo cd and it's a pretty much standard
ci cd process that allows us to
deploy all of our
pipelines just as
kubernetes code
the first step that i wanted to talk
with you is about experimentation
and the question here is
that i'm getting asked a lot from
data scientists in my team yeah so
sometimes i want to use their existing
pipelines which are very robust and
that's a good thing for me
but sometimes somewhere in the media i
want to do some weebly wobbly time and
wine work
and
get some results and then continue the
pipeline from there so how can you
support this type of workflow
where this step should be very
interactive
and the problem is that the experience
is very fragmented if i want to do that
i need to request from my data scientist
to
run um part of the workflow
from the ui and then return back to um
the api and then go back to the react to
the ui and so on and so on
and the solution that we've built for
that is notebook integrations we've
actually built a client and four
notebooks for python which is very nice
to use
uh which allows us to
submit um our workflows with their param
with their parameters from a notebook
wait for results and access the results
even if there are
artifact results which are served on s3
you can install it today using keep
installed you can start argo work for
tools or contribute to
your github
some of the nice things that you can do
with it
so of course you can submit a workflow
which is really nice
if you wish you can suspend uh your
workflow
work
work with it manually or interactively
and then resume it once you feel
comfortable
you can retry a workflow if it makes
sense or if it failed
and of course you can
access to the workflow outputs when
needed
and the really neat part is that you can
actually write your own custom cookbook
um using the previous
python code and just compile it and
run it a doc
to your um
jupyter notebook without actually making
any deployment work or anything like
that so you can actually enjoy both of
the boards working with high skill
argo workflow
and just doing
things
interactively so
the key takeaway from today
so one important aspect before you even
start thinking about how to create an
architecture for your workflow
understand that duality between research
and development understand what it means
for you and how you can transform
between these two modes
one aspect that helped us
mitigate this duality is to treat our
pipelines as code is to think about
pipeline architecture because once we
work with code we can talk about
architecture and abstraction
feeling really well about deployments
and feeling pretty well about how we
combine these interactive
and high scale
robust pipelines
so
um thank you very much everyone um if
you wish to contact me you can find me
that uh on rehab for diagnostic robotics
or you can
post issues or requests on our github
where you will find
all the libraries i've talked about then
we might add in the future examples so
far to use it
and of course um you can talk with me on
the slack channel
that was open for this
purpose components workflows and
cookbooks so thanks everyone
thank you very much i'm ray okay i think
actually time is over so if anyone has a
question please uh don't forget to reach
out omri uh
to the slack channel over gather the
town okay um
so
please um i would like to thank you for
being part of pi data global 2021 number
thank you very much really interesting